- Deux individus ont donc été interpellés
hier soir.
Ils sont soupçonnés d'être les auteurs
des tirs qui ont fait sept blessés à Beaune
dans la nuit du 29 au 30 juillet dernier.
Les deux hommes ont été localisés dans
le Var puis placés en garde à vue.
Depuis l'annonce de la nouvelle dans le quartier
Saint-Jacques de Beaune, c'est le soulagement.
Sur place, les précisions de Gabriel Talon.
- Après l'annonce des interpellations de
deux individus hier soir, ici c'est clairement
un soulagement.
Depuis 13 jours, les habitants du quartier
Saint-Jacques vivaient dans l'angoisse
et dans l'attente de ces interpellations,
pour être certains que cette agression ne soit pas impunie.
Je vous propose d'écouter les réactions
de deux de ces habitants
que nous avons pu rencontrer ce matin.
- Je pense que ça va être un soulagement.
Les gens ont besoin de savoir d'où ils viennent.
C'est légitime de se poser ce genre de question.
Vous êtes qui ? Vous venez d'où ? Et pourquoi
?
Pourquoi agir de telle sorte ?
- Tant mieux pour les victimes.
Comme ça la justice va être faite.
Et puis le calme va être dans le quartier,
parce qu'on y vit beaucoup ici.
J'ai quand même ma compagne et un enfant.
Donc je suis contente pour les victimes.
Et qu'ils prennent soin d'eux et que tout
aille mieux pour eux.
- Autre motif de satisfaction ici, c'est la
qualification des faits par le procureur.
Les deux hommes sont gardés à vue pour tentative
d'assassinat
et violences aggravées par trois circonstances,
dont la motivation raciste du passage à l'acte.
Reste qu'ici dans le quartier Saint-Jacques,
on veut désormais savoir qui sont ces hommes,
d'où viennent-ils et pourquoi ont-ils commis
ces actes.
On attend une communication du procureur de
la République dans les prochaines heures.
Elle devrait intervenir à l'issue des gardes
à vue des deux hommes interpellés.
- Il n'y a plus qu'un jeune blessé toujours
hospitalisé à Dijon.
Une sixième victime est sortie de l'hôpital
ce matin.
Hier, dans la soirée, le procureur de la
République est revenu sur les moyens déployés
pour procéder à l'interpellation de ces
deux tireurs présumés.
Vous trouverez les détails dans un article
sur notre site internet.